well this is a video that new o1 has
asked me to do but I said I would make
it I spent the money to watch it
I spent the time watching it so let's
talk about it Star Wars rebels season 2
so where's rebels season 2 picks up more
or less for Star Wars rebels season 1
left off and Star Wars rebels season 1
the finale we saw that Darth Vader is
coming on the scene is gonna be awesome
he's gonna kick a lot of ass in season 2
he does for a couple episodes that got
his stress I loved seeing Darth Vader in
here he is scary in the season premiere
as a two-parter darth vader steps on
cannons all like that is not an
Inquisitor that's the lord of the sith
we can't beat that guy so they flee and
then you don't see Vader much and in the
meantime in the middle of this until the
season finale we have some filler
episodes of Kanan and Ezra and the crew
of Firefly light going on their
adventures however seem to really
focused up for me what Star Wars rebels
is to our struggles is that adventure
that this new generation can watch and
get hooked on it and then years down the
road they look back biblical Star Wars
rebels that was my jamm which is great
I'm glad that exists for youth today and
it also serves as a much-needed bridge
between Star Wars Clone Wars and Star
Wars the original trilogy like the og
trilogy or at least Star Wars rebels
there's an episode in particular it was
one of my favorites because it dealt
with Rex and his crew they were clone
troopers in the Clone Wars animation so
now it was like Oh order 66 so they go
along with it do they somehow get
through that without actually killing
Jedi I was gaining in the deal with it
was just a really good episode it's a
very personal episode that I really
liked a lot also ahsoka you also saw in
the season finale of season 1 ahsoka
stepping on you're like alright ahsoka
she's gonna kick asses so cos more or
less like gandalf at the beginning of
Fellowship of the Ring gandalf goes to
touch the ring he gleams the Eye of
Sauron he's like uh I think I know what
that is but hold on I got to do some
research I got to find out for sure I'll
be back in a fight ahsoka more or less
gets the impression through the force
like maybe that Darth Vader is my old
master Anakin hold on I gotta go deal
with that I gotta go find out for sure
all right I'll be back she's gone for a
lot of this season which was a bummer
because I wanted to see her in the
season more however she comes back for
the season finale now the season finale
in season two is what got me to watch
Star Wars rebels and Clone Wars at all
because
washed it without watching anything
before and I was like that was really
cool I got to catch up so I caught up
and then I watched it now with context
and it's even better with contact
seriously man they bring in some players
in here there is some conflict going on
and in the end
ahsoka may or may not throw down with
Darth Vader yeah
Anakin sold apprentice may or may not
fight Darth Vader how is that not gonna
be awesome the bummer is I love the
beginning with Darth Vader I love the
end with Darth Vader the filler though
enjoyable and I did have episodes in
there that I really did like and you do
get attached to the crew it wasn't
really what was promised when you say
that Darth Vader is coming on you want
to see Darth Vader throughout you really
didn't which makes me kind of worried
for season 3 it's like Grand Admiral
Thrawn coming on it's like it's Grand
Admiral Thrawn gonna come into season 3
to do [ __ ] throughout season 3 or he's
going to come on for the season premiere
and the season finale guys in the end
Star Wars rebels has come into focus for
me I now see it for what it is and it is
a good thing for sure it is solid
animated entertainment for the youth of
today to watch enjoy now get hooked on
it and then look back when they're
adults and remember and then by the
blu-rays or the digital download
whatever the hell is going to happen 15
years from now what formats are gonna be
on I have no idea but as a guy who if
you follow me on Instagram you saw it I
just been shopped a lot of the old
animated cartoons that I loved as a kid
now I got them now because they take me
back to that time Star Wars rebels can
do that for people I just think that's
great but as enjoyable as Star Wars
rebels season 2 was it was the premiere
and the finale that really brought it
home that's what I wanted to see and
really I can see Star Wars rebels season
3 although I'm excited for them bringing
in throng I'm looking forward to Timothy
Zahn's Thrawn novel more because that's
going to be Thrawn unhinged I can see
Star Wars rebels season 3 being a thing
that I just kind of wait on and then
when it comes out on blue rag and just
binge the entire show I feel like Star
Wars rebels is a better binge than it is
a week-to-week show cuz if I had a tune
in week to week and I'm like alright
it's gonna go down only few episodes
left and they're hanging out with space
whales why are they doing that I just
kind of be irritated but if you're
bingeing you just go on to the next
episode and then the next next and it
doesn't really stick with you like that
Star Wars rebels season 2 is better than
season 1 it's a great adventure given
the context have your kids watch it week
to week you yourself you can probably
binge it when it comes out on blu-ray
season 3 has them
makings of a show that no longer has to
be episodic no longer has to have a lot
of filler filler is gonna happen in any
show I feel like the filler can be
minimized because now you have Darth
Maul you have Darth Vader you have Grand
Admiral Thrawn you have Darth evil you
have the tactician you have the wild
card you have enough no more messing
around let's get it going I feel like
season 3 can be that but don't be
surprised if I just don't watch it week
to week and I just binge it at the end
am I going to review season 3 I don't
know this just all depends on how it
goes so anything about a soak if there's
one thing a Sokka does very well is she
completely negates Padme kind of I mean
not all right so it's not a sexual thing
I'm talking about but the connection
between Anakin and ahsoka is definitely
portrayed as greater than Anakin's
connection with Padme whereas Anakin's
attraction to Padme you feel like is a
sexual physical connection his
connection with ahsoka is like family I
really feel like ahsoka leaving in the
Clone Wars probably left him open to
fall to the dark side much more than
Padme what hurt whatever she did and if
season 3 of rebels hits the point home
that yes ahsoka leaving was actually a
really important thing that really
damaged Anakin he felt like he lost
family I think that's great honestly all
right guys so Star Wars rebels season
two have you seen it what did you think
about it how do you think it compares to
season 1 how do you think season 3 is
going to go whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]